[Musique]
dérangé est ce que vous voulez à céline
je l'offre gratuitement
non mais c'est bien ça vous tente pas je
vous le donne pratiquement la paire
gratuite
monsieur je vous offre facilité un rien
ne m'est pas céline non
monsieur je vous propose ainsi ligne
gratuitement
vous en voulez pas gratuitement c'est
vrai je vous connaissez céline
une frappe du corps
/ mmc ligne dangdang bat céline monsieur
joseph à céline gratuitement mais y'a
rien à la paix un jeune femme
et tous les autres messieurs vous donne
à ces lignes de rapidement vous le
voulez rapidement gratuite lors j'ai
trop gentils ces gentilles spa vous le
connaissez au moins non non vous n'avez
jamais lu non sans un petit pas lecteur
d'avoir oui qu'est ce que vous faites
dans la vie tu rentres retraités et vous
avez jamais entendu le nom de céline
maigné
j'ai tout à fait reproduire c'est un
siège en tgv coupat faire didier si vous
aimez oui j'aime ça mais j'aime beaucoup
ces lignes gm pour des raisons que je ne
peux pas vous raconter notre côté mais
encore parce qu'ils étaient condamnés et
monsieur cinéma été condamné à la
libération
c'est pour ça que vous l'aimez ah oui ça
c'est des raisons extra littéraire il ya
l'eau
je ne suis pas un être de joie je suis
pas un passager soit c'est sa faute a
appris que non j'avoue que je serais
content quand je mourrai
voilà la vérité c'est que je ne désire
mourir de façon la moins douloureuse
possible si tout se passe bien je ne
suis pas coiffés de douleur est-ce qu'il
avait peur de la mort oui s'y attendait
il ya toujours est prêt depuis 18 il
était invalide 75% ça représente un état
très faible n'est ce pas santé donc il
ya toujours lutté et nous en parlait pas
alors si l'on parlait était toujours
avec lui toujours présent pour touristes
est une chose naturelle
il avait des rapports des piscines avec
les gens mais oui parce que d'abord il
n'entendait pas une ride une oreille
donc ça il sait jamais d'où les leçons
il se sentait toujours gêné et puis une
tension nerveuse un petit peu pour
écouter sans doute pour parler ça quand
tu es deux personnes par exemple ne
savait pas d'où mairie sont donc ça ne
le trouble est beaucoup et puis après
les migraines s'enchaînaient le travail
tout ce qu'il peut pour supporter les
mêmes qu'ils soient personnes commandes
y vivaient là confinée dans cette
chambre d'hôtel solitaires même pas au
fond de la grille sur une cadence très
non plus marché de la fin de ce genre il
bougeait plus de sons de son bureau et
salle de marché il avait déserté vite
tomber et puis c'est tellement plus
pendant que votre mari était malade et
qu'il écrivait rigodon il vous avez
interdit de faire venir un médecin si
sur l'état de santé empire est pourquoi
je sais ils prenaient pas beaucoup
d'importance sur lui-même sur ce santé
ça n'était qu'un essai mais qu'il avait
été au bout de ses forces car il met se
savait condamnée au naturel depuis
longtemps depuis sa sortie de 13 ans et
vivait plus beaucoup et il trouvait
ce n'est pas l'otan n'a là que durera le
code est cocu que shoot en voyou
responsable côte en paix tu vas prendre
l'apéro cas unique de respirer viens
voir avec ma ci s'applique aux grandes
salles et tu seras menthe et vient voir
avec moi si sa fille trop grande aux
élèves du ce1
[Musique]
si on prend la vie comme une chose très
amusante badham évidemment l'or en
inventant l'amour est alors un but tout
seul une vérité mais par exemple je ne
suis je n'aime pas ce qui est commun
n'est pas ce que j'ai voulu le dire je
veux dire qu'une prison est une chose
est une chose distinguer parce que
l'homme y souffrent parce que la fête à
neuilly et qu'une chose très vulgaire
parce que je me suis réjoui jeu mais
vous me disiez dans quelles
circonstances vous connaissez bien
comment et par quel espoir c'est loin
c'est très loin gens venaient d'amérique
j'avais quitté dunkerque et je
m'entraînais chez un grand professeur de
l'époque un d'alexandrie et tous les
jours je vais faire quatre ou cinq
heures d'entraînement de leçon et comme
il faut qu'ils s'intéressent à la danse
s'il allait chez les ex-anpe et regardez
le sang c'est ainsi que petit à petit
j'étais assez sauvage dont je cassais
l'ong a accepté de lui parler puis
finalement ça m'a semblé très naturel
vous avez été séduite par le personnage
aaron est extraordinaire comment être
d'abord il était très est pas prêt
aurait été très lointain il avait
quelque chose de mystérieux enfin
j'étais très impossible aux personnages
dans ses rapports pas du tout mais tout
n'était pas là est un être c'était à
quels espoirs qu'il avait déjà il était
déjà connu comme écrivain
il venait d'écrire mon rester dit il
était très fatigué trait là dessus à
chaque fois qu'il faisait année ils
étaient épuisés n'est ce pas m
je crois d'ailleurs dix ans pour fernand
rectrice a été très très doux et il se
sentait fatigué alors pour lui la danse
et une détente il avait été attiré par
le côté surtout le côté travail en 1re
classe il est président vous pouvez
c'est de me décrire quand vous avez
connu nombre d'associés si vous avez il
y avait des yeux tellement où on sortait
temps de cette sixième à deux
personnages étaient des silhouettes
étaient très très belle c'est à dire
juste et il avait les allures de
souplesse de ses gestes d'être gracieux
et moi je suis très impressionné par les
mouvements portes et beaucoup de douceur
dans ses mouvements
il était grand il était très beau mince
et tout était dans l'expression de ses
yeux il était triste songeur
et vous avez vécu avec lui pendant très
longtemps
au moment où j'ai été avec lui j'ai pu
quitter t100 doit-on 36 à 35 36 et sur
qui tu es jeune est ce que vous vous
entendez bien du bio ne riez pas de
problème moi je parlais pas de problèmes
sérieux écoutez c'était pas la peine de
parler mais parlait beaucoup
oui il parle et se laisser aller c'est à
dire c'était pas il n'attendait pas de
réponse alors nous serons entendus dans
très bien comme moi je suis pour le
geste et je n'aime pas besoin de parler
ça ne suffisait pas et c'est ce qu'ils
demandaient
mais tant de soin pour ma part quand il
travaillait une brise est donc le
chapitre le soir de son travail ne l'est
pas pour pour sentir d'abord sans doute
pour s'entendre lui même puisque tout
était rythmée c'était c'était donc un
iep une musique née en même temps sans
doute pour moi je ne peux pas donner mon
avis mais enfin peut-être il essayait de
voir l'effet que cela pouvait faire
quand il est avec quelque chose il
faisait plusieurs versions je crois non
et recommencer sans cesse son ouvrage
jusqu'à temps qu'ils le sentent prêts
alors donc il faisait des ratures mais à
chaque fois il reprenait le tout il
recommencer recommencer
il arrivait à féron dix fois
certainement le livre avant de terminer
n'était jamais content je crois qu'il
aurait pu le faire éternellement m'a
fait un moment donné s'arrêtait mais
c'était des reprises et des rampes liste
du livre en entier ne faisait jamais en
demie avec lui on est maintenant au bout
et qu'est-ce qu'il admirait le plus
dans la vie enfin qu'est ce que prouve
et légèreté les choses qui sont la
poésie devrait priver des toilettes mais
seulement poète je disais beaucoup de
points il aimait les toiles les mais la
fontaine il aimait tout ce qui était la
poésie la musique et des musiciens avant
tout c'est un musicien votre mari avait
bien des défauts vous avez le portrait
d'un homme idéal un homme idéal c'est
pas drôle
qu'est ce qu'il a fait comme défaut oui
oui comme libé pas constitué de lui
c'était un doux mais c'est le principal
c'était très important
peut-être il était assez brusque la
cause jusqu'à six ans de toujours oui il
aimait tant l'amour savane une grande
importance dans sa vie une fois aucune
justement vous prenez vous l'allemand au
cinéma par exemple c'était pas du roman
il n'aimait pas faire des roms
à propos de cinéma il allait souvent au
cinéma ou jamais il ya les cinq minutes
ils avaient compris ça m'allait notre
vie avec avec votre mike vous pourriez
moment par un peu je passe quelques
anecdotes à notre avis elle était très
simple je crois qu'un jour ressemble à
tous les autres jours ils ne dormaient
presque pas donc il était très factuelle
7 heures il fallait qu'il se trouve
enfermé dans sa chambre pour se reposer
sans dormir
moi je ne faisais pas de bruit soit
rester là et je travaillais donc mais
ils sont denses toute la journée j'étais
assez fatigué aussi et nous avions une
vie toujours la même nous sortions
jamais il lui travailler c'est tout les
vapes de force il se remettait à sa
table
autrement ils pensaient sans doute à son
travail naturel vous toujours pas
quelles étaient les compensations pour
vous devez simplement je le voyais temps
en temps il m'appelait nous parlons
c'est tout ça ne suffisait pas
comme ils ne sortaient pas ils
cherchaient à travers moi à savoir un
peu ce qui se passait ce que je voyais à
la télé naissance que j'entende
s'étaient tous ses rapports avec le
monde il n'en avait aucun bus qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pour nord je crois que
honneur en plus nous avons eu un procès
tout de suite à la mort de céline
je crois que c'est
deux mois après les allemands nous ont
fait un procès en diffamation
vous avez été condamné à condenser
famille ou quelque chose comme ça non
mais apparemment de son vivant il ne
pouvait pas vivre nos plus tarder mais
rapporte pas aussi du temps de galles du
temps de noël je crois mais seulement là
ils pensent à l'avenir il voulait pas
finir de soigner à l'hôpital était hanté
par la pauvreté
il voulait rien demandé sa fierté
faisaient qu il voulait se préserver
pour pousser le jour et ça ne lui a pas
réussi puisque cet argent toutes ses
économies
les avait mises dans un coffre en
angleterre après dans un coffre au
danemark
il est 8 heures sans doute de lui
confier son argent à l'abri dans un
coffre dalhemois et quand il a vu que
les allemands allaient aussi au danemark
et ouvrons aussi les coffres à ce moment
là il a une très peur c'est pour ça
qu'il a été deux jours en allemagne pour
donner sa clique de coffre à une
danseuse qui était danoise et qu'il
savait où était la banque pour lui
prendre son argent il est évident qu
enfin s'est exclamé et la liste sous
terre est quelque chose de doux danemark
pensant retrouver cet argent et
danseuses penser que ça lui appartenait
peut-être mais on peut pas dire qu'il
avait un peu l'obsession de la
persécution ou pas du tout il aimait les
gens mais il a tout de suite senti que
en effet que quand on allait au bout des
choses on était fatalement aux victimes
il faut être léger il faut s'en fiche un
peu
et vers la fin de sa vie il regrettait
ce n'était pas un petit peu plus
insouciant il en a parlé
pour les non pas du tout oui qu'est ce
que disait me disaient qu'ils avaient qu
il avait pris la mauvaise direction
c'est tout qu'est ce qu'il aurait
souhaité or dans la vie du défaut et
boxer et jouer de l'accordéon
on va c'est comme ça on s'amuse et puis
on se défend vous comprenez le vis de
cette civilisation petit s'étonnera
petite imitation des civilisations
grecque
c'est qu'elle veut faire tout très vite
n'est ce pas alors c'est un peu la
chansonnette encore une ode à nous
encore une a dit non ce temps prix a
encore eu à l'ambré une amende et une
benne
bon ça c'est de connaître l'argent avait
une grande importance pour saisir oui
parce qu'il est détestée de mépriser
absolument les geôles birmanes ce que l
on parlait tout le temps me dit qu'on
aurait pu verser les sommes les plus
fantastiques
lui qui aimait tant sa liberté 5 lui
permettent absolument de tout ce qu'il
voulait c'est à dire partir sur les
bords de la maine et meklouche et de la
toux les maux
donc l'argent pour lui c'est
l'indépendance et de faire ce qu'il veut
dire partir sur un bateau et puis c'est
tout il parraine dans la mer
moi si j'étais dictateur décidément
c'est une manie je ferai passer une
autre loi une encore et c'est la
dernière
premièrement tous les juifs sur ce
territoire dès la déclaration de guerre
de 17 à 60 ans demi car de juifs matinée
maria des juives francs maçons sont
affectés uniquement aux unités
d'infanterie combattante et de première
ligne
troisièmement toute infraction à ces
articles sera puni de la peine de mort
sans discussion ni murmure donc tous les
juifs en première ligne pas de
billevesées pad et stéphane et pendant
toute la durée de la guerre aucun
privilège admis les blessés juifs ne
seront jamais évacués de la zone des
armées il guériront dans la zone des
armes et ils crèveront s'il le faut dans
la zone des armées il fait condron la
zone des armées il faut se méfier
toujours des juifs même quand ils sont
morts
et alors c'est assez étonnant de
l'entendre 10 au plus tôt devoir écrire
bon il faudra mettre tous les juifs
femmes et enfants de premier rang et
puis c'est affreux de penser qu'avec une
phrase on plaît que jeune mais c'est
grave très grave mais il n'a pas fait de
sentiments vous savez widadi sable dans
un moment de colère comme moi il mardi
enfin il m'a dit des choses comme ça à
moi qui me prend je sais qu'il m'aimait
bien il m'a dit de telles expressions
mais si vous prenez l'expression
elle-même vous allez tous les monstrueux
et ça je n'ai plus rien et comment se
fait-il qu'il n'ait jamais exprimé de
regret parce qu'au fond même pendant la
guerre quand il a vu les massacres se
produit il n'en savait rien ces
massacres
ce que vous appelez massa c'est à dire
des camps de concentration mais elle a
toujours ignoré et à tous les moyens
mais quand tu es rafle du vel d'hiv
paris les juifs tout paris l'a su
maintenant on le voit se séparer ces
choses là je ne pense pas qu'il a plus
de savoir vous voyez bien des juifs se
promener dans la rue des étoiles
oui c'est le voyait ni il ne connaît pas
le problème du même point de vue
peut-être je ne sais pas qui ne voulait
surtout pas s'en mêler aux
l'antisémitisme ça je crois qu'il en a
toujours parlé c'est l'époque où si
c'est son époque c'est affaire dreyfus
sont ses parents c'est tout
toute sa jeunesse peut-être n'est-ce pas
moi j'en ai entendu parler aussi chez
moi parce que sans doute il fut un temps
où on en est
c'était sans doute se sont à 36 ans
qu'il l'a rendu comme sentissi mythe si
l'on peut dire il voulait mais il était
de ce qu'il était ces méthodes ils se
trouvent celte le je ne sais pas moi je
peux pas parler de racisme ribéry mais
il se trouvait être ce qu'ils étaient
d'une certaine consistance d'une
centaine certaines choses et c'est
simple mais peut-être qu'on attend qu'on
a peur est-ce que lieux des attentats
commis contre céline 17 heures je crois
qu'il avait pas mal de gens qui est venu
de supprimer c'est tout mais je me suis
native direct non il en est menacé en
rit beaucoup pour cette nous sommes
partis d'un dans la vie et l'oeuvre de
ces merveilles si on a l'impression que
c'est une préfiguration de son propre
destin parce qu'il raconte l'histoire
des personnages plus quand on se dit
quelque chose on est certainement mal
compris et puis il ya
c'est fatal quoi c'est en effet un
destin qui est très similaire au sien
philippe il ya samuel weis 1818 1865
médecin juif hongrois découvre que la
fièvre puerpérale est transmise aux
femmes enceintes par les mains sales des
médecins il réduit la mortalité de 20 %
à 4 %
lavez vous les mains demande semmelweis
à ses patrons chasser et persécuté il
meurt fou enfin il était tout seul il
s'était rangé pour ça aussi
n'oubliez pas une chose c'est clément a
lui appris c'est la mort si vous mettez
pas votre peau sur la table vous n'avez
rien il faut payer
[Musique]